aprobado y se empacha a ley entre
aplausos y festejos chile aprobó el
matrimonio igualitario la iniciativa fue
revisada y aprobada por la cámara de
diputados de chile con 82 votos a favor
20 en contra y 2 abstenciones luego de
que el senado horas antes diera luz
verde al proyecto cuesta creerlo que hoy
día estamos dando este paso pero este
paso se pudo dar gracias a que hemos
trabajado durante años en el cambio
cultural profundo el código civil y el
de trabajo fueron modificados a la par
con la aprobación se permite el
matrimonio entre parejas del mismo sexo
la adopción homoparental y se regula los
derechos del cuidado de menores derechos
laborales y la no discriminación de las
personas trans la iniciativa entró al
parlamento en 2017 con el visto bueno de
la ex presidenta michelle bachelet pero
durante cuatro años no tuvo avances
importantes y no fue hasta junio de este
año que el presidente piñera pidió a los
parlamentarios darle la prioridad pienso
que ha llegado el tiempo del matrimonio
igualitario en nuestro país
por esta razón
anunciamos que pondremos urgencia al
proyecto de ley que lleva años en el
congreso chile se convierte en el octavo
país de américa latina en legalizar el
matrimonio igualitario después de
argentina uruguay brasil colombia
ecuador costa rica y varios estados de
mexico
la decisión legislativa llega a escasos
días de la segunda vuelta electoral
donde los candidatos presidenciales que
participan tienen posturas supuestas
respecto a los derechos lgtb y el
proyecto se convertirá en ley una vez
que sebastián piñera lo promulga y 90
días después los primeros matrimonios
entre personas del mismo sexo podrían
empezar a celebrarse